I grew up on a beef Farm in Missouri and
like everybody else that raises
livestock we raise a lot of our own feed
to stay in business and we raise corn
and soybeans and hay and we grind this
stuff up into a flower and we'd add
vitamins and minerals and trace minerals
make pellets and you feed those Cales
for about 6 nine months and then you
ship them off to be butchered or maybe
to other feeders and you always save
back the very best ones for yourself and
you knock him in the head and eat him
it's a real simple cycle on the farm and
the thing that fascinated me as a
teenager was that we went to a great
deal of trouble for those calves and yet
as a family we ate out of the very same
Fields we'd keep back five rows of corn
for oursel we had a garden at the end of
the field where we grew our peas and
beans and squash and tomatoes and we
wanted to live to be a h hundred with no
aches and pains and we didn't give
ourselves the very same vitamins and
minerals and trace minerals that we gave
the calvs and I always used to ask my
dad I say hey Pops how come we go to all
that trouble for those calvs and and not
for ourself and he'd say shut up boy
getting Farm Fresh Food fresh air lots
of free exercise don't ask complicated
questions and I was glad to get rid of
the farm exercise and go to a school at
the University of Missouri and there my
major was in animal husbandry and
nutrition my minor was in field crops
and soils and I began to learn technical
things about soil chemistry and how it
related to tons and bushels per acre and
a economics but I didn't get an answer
to my basic question until I became a
freshman Veterinary student at the
University of Missouri and there I
learned that the reason why we put all
these vitamins and minerals and trace
minerals into animal feeds bottom line
is because we don't have insurance for
them we don't have Blue Cross Blue
Shield major medical hospitalization
Medicare Medicaid and if we were to use
a human health care type of system for
Animals it'd be sticker shock for you
your hamburger would cost you $275 a
pound boneless skinless chicken breast
be 450 bucks a pound dozen eggs would be
$50 just to pay for the health care so
we learned that we could keep the price
of animal products such as meat and
dairy and poultry and eggs down to where
the aage average American could afford
them simply by significantly reducing or
totally eliminating health care cost and
we do that in Animals by preventing and
curing diseases with nutrition well
after graduating vet school I went to
Africa for a couple of years and got to
work with Marlon Perkins from the old
Mutual of Omaha Wild Kingdom days that
was kind of a kick got to play Frank
Buck used a tranquilizer gun Trump all
over Central and South Africa for a
couple of years and then Marlin sent me
a telegram and invited me back to the
States uh he'd gotten a $7.5 million
Grant from the national Institutes of
Health and this was more than 30 years
ago and this was to study pollution and
ecology and the environment and my job
as the Wildlife veterinarian on the
project was to do autopsies of animals
that died of natural causes in the big
zoos around the United States and I was
supposed to identify or find a species
of animals that was Ultra sensitive to
pollution and we're going to use that
animal much like the old coal miners
used to use canaries you know how that
goes they take the canary down in the
mine and if methane gas or carbon
monoxide were to leak into the mine the
canaries were more sensitive than the
men and uh would drop off the Persian
die and long before the men were in
danger of suffocating or blowing up well
to make a long story short after some 12
plus years of working on this project
and done some 17,500 autopsies and over
454 species of animals plus 3,000 human
beings for a comparison and what I
learned was that every animal and human
being who dies of natural causes dies of
a nutritional deficiency disease and I
got kind of excited about nutrition
again and I wrote 75 scientific papers
on the subject uh wrote chapters for
eight multi-author textbooks actually
contributed a textbook myself a thousand
Pages 2,000 illustrations and uh through
the news releases that were in the big
universities I worked with I was on 2020
was in 1700 newspapers around the world
through the UPI and AP newswire services
and with all this public exposure and
with all this scientific exposure I
couldn't get people who are in a
position of authority either in medical
research or in politics to get two
concerned or interested in preventing
and curing diseases in human beings with
nutrition just like we did in animals
well I got frustrated enough I went back
to school in Portland argon and became a
physician and I practiced there for 12
years as a general family practitioner
and Uh I seed up chainsaw wounds
delivered babies um used everything that
I'd learned in Veterinary nutrition of
my human patients and it was no surprise
to me that it worked just as well in
people as it did in animals well to get
started I always like to talk about
longevity and the human being has the
genetic potential to live healthily to
be 120 I'm going to prove that to you in
just a minute unfortunately Americans do
a lousy job when it comes to longevity
our average lifespan in the United
States is 75.5 about half we're
genetically capable of in 1990 when the
World Health Organization examined the
top 32 industrialized nations on Earth
the United States came out 17th there
was actually 16 other countries whose
peoples live longer than we do we ranked
19th in healthfulness that meant that
there were 18 other countries whose
peoples live longer than than we do
before they develop heart disease and
cancer and diabetes and arthritis and
osteoporosis we ranked 23rd when it came
to live births and first year surviv
abilities of babies and we ranked dead
last 32 out of 32 when it came to
preventing birth defs now what all this
means is we have the highest priced
Health Care system in the world but not
the best it also means that we have the
most envied Health Care system in the
world but not the best we have the most
technologically advanced Health Care
system in the world but not the best I
had a good friend by the name of
Christopher Bur for many many years over
20 years and Chris was a bestselling
author on books on AR ganly grown food
he was an expert in this subject and I
was always trying to give him vitamins
and minerals and he refused to take them
and he'd tell me Doc I bring my own
cooler I don't eat any uh Hotel food I
bring my own organically grown food and
so I don't need to take vitamins and
minerals well I was changing planes
again in Atlanta had an hour to kill
picked up the local newspaper and guess
who obituary I found in the newspaper
Chris bird of course again he was a
bestselling author of books of The
Secret life of plants the secrets of the
soil and he died at age 68 from a
ruptured aneurysm a type of stroke 7 and
1/2 years before the average American
dies and he led a pristine life lived up
in the mountains had an organically
grown Garden collected herbs you know
like Ule Gibbons and ate wild Hickory
nuts and all those kind of things and
because of his belief he died of a
copper deficiency and I'll show you in a
minute that copper deficiency causes
ruptured aneurisms it's just a tragic
thing that that people have so much to
give and die at less than half their
genetic potential for longevity a lot of
people say to me Doc I don't need to
take vitamins and minerals and trace
minerals because I use herbs now herbs
are not nutrition you have to understand
that herbs are not nutrition they are
great plant medicines uh they're safer
they're more economical and most cases
are more effective than prescription
medications that doctors will give you
but they're plant medicines if you have
diarrhea they can tighten you up if you
have constipation they can loosen you up
if you have hypertension or high blood
pressure they can bring it down if you
have a fever and bring it down but don't
expect to get enough calcium or selenium
or Boron or copper or vitamin A from
herbs well I've been doing biomedical
research and Clinical Research in
animals and human beings and I can tell
you no matter how you look at Health and
Longevity whether it be in animals or
human beings there's only really two
concepts you have to deal with Concept
number one I refer to is avoid stepping
on the landmines this is where you don't
want to throw away your Healthy physical
body wastefully you don't want to smoke
don't abuse alcohol don't do drugs don't
jog down the highway at 2 o'clock in the
morning wearing an all black ninja suit
you're going to get hit by a truck
mirror right whenever a doctor says
here's our options never say doc
whatever you say you're the you're the
doctor when the doctor says here's our
options what you want to do is say look
I want copies of all these records and
tests I want copies of the x-rays and go
visit three other doctors and three
other hospitals you want to talk to 12
of their living patients that had gone
through this procedure talk to them see
if you really want to do this I mean you
do this for your driveway and your roof
and your fence and your yard and all
that kind of stuff why not for your own
physical body that's concept number one
now that you've avoided the landmines
you're in a good position to do all the
positive things that you need to do to
go on to live the your over 100
basically what you want to do is take
all the essential nutrients 60 that's 60
minerals 16 vitamins 12 essential amino
acids and three essential fatty acids
and they're called essential nutrients
for two reasons number one your body
cannot manufacture them you must consume
these every day either as food or
supplements number two if any one of
these essential nutrients is missing for
a couple of months couple of years you
get on the average 10 deficiency
diseases you have everything to gain
nothing to lose by supplementing
properly well the medical profession of
course has this malignant dumb belief
that you can get everything you need
from your four food groups my favorite
article of all time in the Press was
April 6 1992 Time Magazine cover article
the real power of vitamins new research
shows it may help fight cancer heart
disease and the ravages of Aging six
positive Pages if you haven't read it
I'd urge you to go to a public library
School library dig it out and read it
there was only one negative sentence and
as you might guess it was offered by a
medical doctor who was actually U
contacted by the writer of the article
said what do you think about vitamins
and minerals and and trace minerals as
supplements for human nutrition here's
what he said quote popping vitamins
doesn't do you any good sniffs Dr Victor
Herbert a professor of medicine at New
York City's Mount siai medical school we
get all the vitamins we need in our
diets and taking supplements just gives
you expensive urine unquote now Missouri
translation of that is you're just
peeing away your money you might as well
W up your dollars throw them in a toilet
and flush them away you can get
everything you need from your four food
groups is what he's trying to say well
I'd rather pee out 50 cents or a dollar
a day worth of excess vitamins and
minerals that's cheap insurance think
about it how much money you spend for
coffee or soft drinks or newspapers and
that kind of stuff every day 50 cents to
a dollar a day to maintain and repair
your body and it's kind of fascinating
that most people don't do it just
remember when you pay that doctor out of
your own pocket or indirectly through
insurance or indirectly through taxes
and Medicare Medicaid not a single penny
of that goes to better understand manage
treat prevent or cure catastrophic
diseases in kids breast cancer in women
prostate cancer in men and a lot of
people ask me why did you call your
original tape Dead Doctors Don't Lie
well that's because I I believe for a
long time because I'd done medical
research for over 20 years in large
medical research instit institutes
medical schools the various Laboratories
and I always had a belief in the medical
system but I was very disappointed when
I learned that doctors don't know the
most about Health and Longevity doctors
don't know the most about disease they
do know about procedures you know how to
fix your bones when you break them and
that sort of thing how to do a CAT scan
and so I began to look in the medical
journals and sure enough the first
article ever published on Health and
Longevity of American doctors was
published in jamama in June 15th 1895 a
little over 100 years ago they said at
that time doctors lived to be
54.6 I redid the study 97 years later
using the same obituary techniques that
they did in jamama This was um January
20th 1993 that particular issue of
jamama and it turned out the doctors Liv
to be 57.6 I rounded up to 58 to give
them the benefit of the doubt and
doctors just went berserk when I said
that I mean this was the most outrageous
thing that they ever heard my principle
is my my premise is that doctors don't
live as long as the average couch potato
in America and I purposely put that
figure out there at 58 to try and
challenge people well doctors
immediately looked at all the insurance
Actuarial charts they got 250,000 Dead
Doctors he said your group's too small
so they looked at 250,000 dead doctors
they say doctors don't live to be 58
they died 62 they still don't live to be
75.5 like the average couch potato we
actually reran this again using the
entire obituary history for 1996 and for
the entire 1996 of all the doctors dying
in 1996 with all the medical treatments
and drugs and and procedures and
everything and transplants doctors in
that study lived to be 70 still 5 and 1
half years short of the average couch
potato in America so they still have
never proven that Doctors live as long
as everybody else and that's why Dead
Doctors Don't
Lie now if you do everything right how
old can you live to be is it worth all
the effort I believe it is here's one
Christian mortensson from San Rafel
California in August of 1995 turned 113
August from 1996 he turned 114 he's
still going strong certainly can live to
be be 115 smokes a couple of cigars a
day like George Burns who also lived to
be over 100 certainly was I guess the
only exercise George Burns ever did was
put the cigars in his mouth this gal
here Dora rathebe from South Africa in
July of 1995 turned 114 and when she was
asked by the media Dora what do you
attribute Your Health and Longevity to
she did not say that we owe it all to
our annual physical r r HMO she said I
ate Locust every day you know a little
grasshopper she's not a vegetarian she's
little animals pumpkin seeds tortoise
meat wild herbs dried fruit and starts
each day with a cup of coffee this gal
here Margaret SKS from Radford Virginia
in 1994 was the oldest documented living
American when she died at age 115 fell
over and fractured her hip three weeks
later she was dead from complications of
osteoporosis a simple Calcium deficiency
and we'll talk more about this in a
minute unfortunately this is not unusual
75% of all Americans over the age of 65
who fracture hip or major leg bone don't
live 90 days they dive pneumonia
pulmonary embolism stroke and other
complications of that fracture Susie
Brunson according to her family in
December of 1994 was the oldest American
when she died at age of 123 and they
based her claim on her birth date
December 25th 1870 which was recorded in
the Family Bible and this fellow here
Francisco barison wave of Cho Arina
October 1995 he was from a little town
outside of bogat Columbia turned 125
when he was asked by the media Francisco
what do you attribute Your Health and
Longevity to he said well I drink a
gallon of ghats milk every day also it's
kind of fascinating and his birthday
announcement this is not an obituary
this is birthday announcement said that
over 40 years ago his Physicians told
him he only had a couple of months to
live so he had his sons build him a
coffin and uh he's been waking up every
morning for more than 40 years sitting
by that coffin waiting to
die good night time comes he goes to bed
wakes up the next morning sits by the
coffin waits to die now he's still going
strong and all the doctors who told him
that more than 40 years ago are long
since dead now this fellow here Hamudi
Al Abdullah from Syria died age 133 and
he was still fing children after the age
of 100 he um remarried for the fourth
time when he was age 80 fathered four
boys five girls nine children after the
age of 80 with the same wife and we add
up the pregnancies and the breastfeeding
the time in between pregnancies he was
still fathering children after the age
of 100 now this very next one is my very
very favorite this Gale maumi Dy from
Iran according to the Rocky Mountain
news wire Services out of Denver and the
Iranian news agency this was January of
1995 she died at age of 161 now you have
to give a certain amount of credibility
to this obituary report that she died at
age 161 because she was survived by six
living children ranging in age from 120
to 128 they hadn't even left home to go
to college
yet now her oldest son Golam said his
mother had never visited a doctor nor
taking any chemical medications during
her life did take a few herbs so if you
kind of think about it every one of
these people who Liv to be over 100 120
130 160 these people are not from you
United States or Canada or Germany or
England kind of interesting isn't it
they're most of them are from third
world countries they're furthest away
from medical help and they live to be
old so that we're beginning to collect
information here the last one we want to
look at the National Geographic Society
a very respected group of people
scientists and so forth and support
groups for science uh comes out with a
monthly magazine the National Geographic
magazine of course and they uh in
January of 1973 came out with a Nifty
special issue on longev they looked at
cultures whose people live to be 120 and
they documented the oldest living human
being that they could find based on
their criteria this fellow by the name
of shal misala from azerbijan a little
country just south of Russian Georgia
and Western Russia today they documented
him as being 167 years old remember this
is the National Geographic Society not
the national inquir 167 years of age and
they had a half-page picture of him
actually harvesting tea leaves in a Tea
Plantation still working 8 hours a day 6
days a week when he's 167 5 months later
May of 1973 charal molof turns 168 goes
out and H the garden for reporters to
show how vigorous he is now for at least
50 maybe 70 years medical doctors in
America have been poo pooing the idea
that you could live well beyond 100 you
know people who lived 115 120 they were
one in6 billion it wasn't something that
everybody could look forward to and
anybody who tried to teach people how to
live to be 110 120 140 were considered
charlatans and quacks and taking
advantage of uh older people I was glad
to see this come out this was a news
article in the USA Today newspaper in
October of 2000 and it was based on a
article in the journal science very
respectable journal and what they said
was forget 100 try living past
120 humans possess a maximum life
expectancy longer than 120 years which
had been the long theorized medical
limit in fact lifespans appear to be
increasing over time with no end in
sight now the cute part of this is now
that there's no doubt about it everybody
agrees that human beings including
Americans have the genetic capacity to
live well beyond 120 doctors want to
take credit for it the things that have
actually increased our longevity from 45
average lifespan in 1895 to 75.5 today
which is an increase of about 30 and a
half years are sewers and good clean
water public health things we don't have
chalera and leptospirosis and
tuberculosis in our food supply or water
supply anymore we have Meat Inspection
we have public water works and things we
have sewers these are the things that
have extended our lifespan then there's
this salt thing now whether you believe
it or not this medical Dogma has really
caused a lot of problems in America how
many you ever heard that using the salt
shaker is bad you're going to get
hypertension right you're going to get
heart disease and stroke what's the
first thing a good farmer puts sou for's
livestock a salt block or Salt Lick
isn't it there's nobody out in the
pasture telling a cow she's limited to
one lick a
day I refuse to believe that my human
patients are ding a cow say look go
ahead and pick up a salt Shake you're
going to see that lightning won't strike
you you can go ahead and salt your food
to tast you salt your body nothing bad
is going to happen and 98% of my
patients love it they bring me hundreds
of new patients every month who want to
use salt and not feel guilty about it
and 2% the bean counters they say now w
we love you and respect you we have this
high price cardiologist that says you're
flying in the face of all the weight and
medical evidence you can't tell people
that um they can use a salt shaker
because you're going to kill them with
high blood pressure and heart disease
and stroke and I've been Vindicated in
this belief this was actually a study
that was published in the New York Times
May 22nd 1996 and this study was
abstracted from jamama the Journal of
the American Medical Association the
most prestigious medical journal in the
world according to
themselves now in this particular
journal A Dr Alexander Gordon Logan who
is an epidemiologist and cardiologist on
the teaching staff of the medical school
at the University of Toronto up in
Canada and he took 56 existing studies
on hypertension or high blood pressure
and restriction of salt
combined the data from these 56 studies
which included 355 people he threw away
all the conclusions and reevaluated the
larger group and what he found out was
this if you have normal blood pressure
and you restrict salt it will not
prevent you from getting heart disease
or high blood pressure if you have
hypertension or high blood pressure and
restrict salt 97% of those with high
blood pressure or hypertension who
restrict salt will not get any
measurable benefit 97% will not get any
measurable benefit zero 2 to 5% get
measurable benefit but it's not
significant they're only able to reduce
their blood pressure by 3.7 millimet of
mercury so here's what Dr Alexander
Gordon Logan said in jamama May 22nd
1996 he said you might as well go ahead
and salt your food to taste it's a
meaningless exercise don't get paranoid
about salt it has nothing to do with
blood pressure problems there has never
been one single iota of proof that
restricting salt has any benefit it's
just one of those medical myths he
called it but I'm going to call it a
medical cocka now if it's not salt what
causes high blood pressure well it's not
salt first of all because salt is an
essential nutrient is a combination of
sodium and chloride both of which you
need and according to the American Heart
Association the minimum daily
requirement for 150 PB person for salt
each day is a heaping teaspoon 69 gam of
salt today now the Japanese who live
longer than we do the Japanese who live
4.1 years longer than we do and have
half the cancer rate they eat 12 grams
of salt a day they eat three times the
salt we do and they live four years
longer have half the cardiovascular
disease
rate and half the cancer rate we do and
yet they eat three times as much salt as
we do so you're beginning to put the
puzzle together that doctors really
don't know what they're talking about
that's why Dead Doctors Don't Lie well
if it's not the salt and if it's not
genetic what is it well it's actually
just a simple mineral deficiency raise
your hand you ever heard that
cholesterol is bad and you got to get it
low in your blood you got to have a low
cholesterol diet otherwise you're going
to get heart disease right doctors would
like to blame all cardiovas disease on
cholesterol we've known for 75 years in
the animal industry that cholesterol is
not a boogeyman there's not a single
disease that's caused by elevated blood
cholesterol triglycerides you can find
me one I'll give you a million dollars
in small bills in any offshore account
you want there's not a single disease
that's caused by elevated blood
cholesterol or triglycerides elevated
blood cholesterol and triglycerides are
really just a warning signal much like a
fever fevers don't cause infections but
when you have an infection with a
bacteria a virus a fungus be a parasite
you can get a fever you can have a
broken leg and get a fever you can have
cancer and get a fever you can have
liver disease and get a fever babies get
a fever when they teethe and so you have
to kind of sort it out when somebody
comes into a doctor's office with a
fever you have to say well okay here's
my whole list called a differential
diagnosis all the things that cause
fever if they're 80 years old you can
quickly rule out teething
right but the rest of you may have to do
some lab tests for them any rate the
same thing is true for elevated blood
cholesterol and triglycerides when you
have elevated blood cholesterol and
triglycerides it might mean that you
have hypothyroidism or low functioning
thyroid gland you could have diabetes
you could have deficiencies of nasin
chromium vadium the essential fatty
acids you could have liver disease all
kinds of reasons why you might have
elevated blood cholesterol and
triglycerides but they in themselves
don't cause any problems now the eskimos
above the Arctic Circle have a
traditional diet that's 98% red meat and
blubber uh they whale meat whale blubber
walrus meat walis blubber seal meat seal
blubber bare meat bare fat there's not a
single Eskimo above the Arctic Circle
that has Mr juice man juicer eats
organically grown
broccoli their average cholesterol
ranges from 250 to 350 and yet they're
legendary for not getting cardiovascular
disease until they come down to the
lower 48 and eat like us then when they
get the cardiovascular disease they go
back home to die up above the Arctic
Circle they start eating whale blubber
again it goes away well learning all
that I felt very confident in telling my
patients look we're going to do
something different my goal as a
position is to have my patients die at
an average age of 100 I don't want my
patients dying at 75.5 I want to give
them another 25 years I want the average
lifespan for my patients to be 100 and
we're going to do something different if
you want to do everything that all the
other doctors and patients are doing I
want you to go to them because I don't
want you to lower my average right we're
going to do something different it's
just real simple my favorite disease is
arthritis I love arthritis the reason
why I love arthritis is it's easy to fix
and when you can fix something as
horrible and as debilitating as painful
and as expensive and as miserable as
arthritis you get kind of excited about
this concept of preventing and curing
diseases with nutrition and so I tell
people about this arthritis thing all
the time so let's have a quick look at
arthritis uh number one 75 to 80% of all
Americans over the age of 50 get
arthritis to one degree or of one type
or another and according to the CDC the
Center for Disease Control 35 to 50
million baby boomers are going to get
arthritis in the next 7 to 10 years and
there's not a single medical treatment
designed to prevent or fix it aspirin
certainly doesn't fix arthritis causes
gastric bleeding and death tanol doesn't
fix arthritis causes 50,000 cases of
kidney failure each year 5,000 which are
so severe you need a kidney transplant
then there's ibuprofen ad vill and a
leave these things don't fix arthritis
and they cause liver disease in 2 to 5%
of the users including liver ceros even
if you don't drink and then there's
Methotrexate and gold shots these things
don't fix arthritis they subdue your
bone marrow so you can't make normal
platelets and white blood cells and then
you have the granddaddies of all the
medical treatments for arthritis prazone
and cortisone they don't fix arthritis
they subdue your immune system which
leaves you open to diseases far far more
horrible than arthritis and prazone and
cortisone accelerate the loss of
minerals from your bone something you
don't want when you have osteoporosis
and arthritis now when these
prescription medications and
over-the-counter medications don't work
anymore to relieve pain and inflammation
the only thing left for you medically is
joint replacement surgery and uh I I
never like to send my patients in for
the joint replacement surgery because
they never work out well in fact many
times you're worse off after the surgery
than you were before the surgery the
advantage my patients have always had is
that I'm a veterinarian as well as a
physician and so I always used to tell
my patients look we have all these
nutritional formulas designed to prevent
and cure diseases in animals including
arthritis and so I tried adapting
nutritional arthritis formula is
designed to prevent and cure arthritis
in pigeons and turkeys dogs cats sheeps
pigs horses cows lions tigers and bears
to human use it was no surprise to me it
works just as well in humans as it does
in animals because it was designed to
prevent and cure arthritis and pigs and
I've literally seen tens of thousands of
people who've had a regrowth of
cartilage ligaments tendons connective
tissue bone Foundation bone Matrix
doesn't matter if they're 20 30 40 50 60
70 80 90 I've seen people 97 years old
regrow caragen bone even if they had
bone to bone arthritis if there's blood
supply to that joint in that bone they
will regrow uh bone and carage well of
course Harvard Medical School goes
berserk when you say stuff like that W
you can't say those things the only
thing left for people when they get bone
to bone arthritis is joint replacement
surgery and I I'd agree with him that
the only raw materials you're using is
Tylenol and aspirin and prazone and
cortisone we've learned over 50 years
that you can't regrow car bone using
those things one of the basic things of
course that the Harvard Medical School
jumped on to and they said this is so
ridiculous that this couldn't work and
so they took 29 patients arthritis
patients who had failed to respond in
any way to heroic medical treatment for
arthritis over 15 to 20 years they took
them off all their medication wasn't
working for him anyway lined them up for
joint replacement surgery and they said
look for 90 days before we do the
surgery they gave him a heaping
tablespoon full of ground up chicken
carage and their orange juice every
morning for 90 days they were sort of
chuckling in their beer saying nothing's
going to happen well here's what
happened in 10 days these people these
29 people had complete relief of pain
inflammation something they hadn't had
in 15 to 20 years in 30 days they could
Now open up a new pickle jar that never
been opened without pain to the fingers
wrists elbows and shoulders in 90 days
28 of the 29 were clinically cured now
this is from Harvard Medical School in
the Boston VA that meant that they had
complete return to the range of otion
all the pain inflammation was gone and
their fingers and toes and hips and
knees and their neck and certainly many
of them still had knots on their fingers
because it was only 90 days and you'd
think they'd call me up these professors
you know of medicine from Harvard
Medical School and from the Boston VA
and sayl wallet we have to apologize to
you we've been bad mouthing you for 20
years and why don't you come up to
Boston let's talk about the whole thing
here's what they said quote after 3
months it was clear that the drug was
beneficial unquote chicken cartilage had
become a drug in 90
days now why would that happen well
because you can't patent chicken carage
and uh they convinced at the US patent
office that they were using a drug to do
this study and they actually got a use
patent on chicken carage and you two for
3500 bucks a month can get Harvard
Medical school's chicken carage in a
capsule for arthritis of course
cartilage has Condren sulfate in it
glucosamine sulfate collagen these are
all the basic raw materials to rebuild
carage and Bone raise your hand if you
know what the red warning lies for on
the dashboard of a car truck back before
we had dials showing temperatures and
things they used to use the red warning
light right it was called The Idiot
light and when that red warning light
came on it meant that your engine was
heating up you didn't have have enough
coolant or oil or maybe you broke a fan
belt or split a radiator hose and a
reasonable person would would pull the
vehicle car or truck over the side of
the road and deal with the problem so
you didn't burn the engine up even even
a Mercedes would burn up if you didn't
have enough coolant and oil and a fan
belt and radiator hose then of course
the village idiot that's why they call
it the Village Idiot light or the idiot
light they'd be driving along they see
that red warning light come on they say
I don't have time to deal with this so
they whip out their plowers they cut the
wire of the red warning light they keep
on driving even a Mercedes will burn up
if it doesn't have oil cool in a fan
belt and a radiator hose right and so
you really have to be The Village Idiot
to do that nobody in the right mind
would do that to their vehicle how many
of you know what pain is for a raise
your hand if you know it pain is far
that's pretty good most of you know that
pain is the red warning light for your
body when you get pain in your foot your
ankle your leg your knee your hip your
back your shoulders elbows wrist and
fingers your body saying don't use those
joints don't use those bones don't use
those muscles until you fix them it's
absolutely criminal absolutely criminal
for a doctor to write you a prescription
for a pain reliever an anti-inflammatory
or muscle relaxing or any of those
combinations without rebuilding the
bones and the joints and the cartilage
at the same time if they just give you a
pain reliever just give you an
anti-inflammatory andar muscle relaxment
without rebuilding the joints and the
bones at the same time all they're doing
is cutting the wire of the red warning
light you're going to wear those bones
and joints and cartilage out faster and
faster and faster it's actually a
negative to be taking painkillers and
anti-inflammatories without rebuilding
the joints and the bones at the same
time the reason why I say no carbonated
drinks and I've been doing that since
1964 is because carbonated drinks
actually will neutralize your stomach
acid and you cannot efficiently absorb
minerals digest protein or absorb
vitamin B12 without stomach acid you
have to have stomach acid like battery
acid doctors have the criminal belief
that you don't need stomach acid and
they give you all these drugs to get rid
of your stomach acid ant acids and they
give you drugs to stop producing stomach
acid right they don't want you to have
stomach acid absolutely criminal you
can't digest food and absorb food
without stomach acid I know most of you
knew that carbonat drinks neutralized
stomach acid if you remember back 25 50
75 years ago when somebody would ask her
doctor to say look I just ate a i
overate i overate a Thanksgiving dinner
and I have heartburn and indigestion
what do I do that was before they had
Zantac they say well take some seven up
drink some ginger ale drink some club
soda take take some uh sparkling water
because the carbonation will neutralize
your stomach acid and give you some
relief in a wood now if you do that
three times a year drink a carbonated
drink three times a year for
Thanksgiving and Christmas and Easter
because you overeat during those
holidays that's okay you're going to
survive but when you're drinking two
three four five 6 8 10 carbonated drinks
a day you're not going to survive
because over the long haul you will not
be able to absorb the nutrients you're
going to get some horrible combination
of terrible diseases this came out June
of 2000 and this is a Harvard study on
460 junior high school girls in n9th and
10th grade and what they found out was
that those Junior High School girls who
drank One n nonca carbonator drink every
day they increase their risk of
fractures and osteoprosis as a teenager
by 300% they found out that if they
drank one carbonated Cola drink a cola
carbonated drink every day they increase
the risk of fractures and osteoprosis as
a teenager by
500% now do you think that this is more
dangerous for teenagers or adults it's
much more dangerous for adults because
you only have 25% bone matrix and you're
very very slow to recover where
teenagers have 40% bone matrix and they
can recover in a week's time we learned
in 1957 from a turkey study uh where
they took 250,000 turkeys and they put
them on a complete turkey pellet trying
to get them to finish for Market within
a few days or a week or so of each other
and in the first 13 weeks fully half of
them 125,000 of them died farmers were
out there every morning they picked them
up every morning by the bushel basket
full took them to the state Diagnostic
lab to see what they died from when they
opened them up every one of them had
died of a ruptured a Artic aneurysm and
one of the clever pathologist says
that's got to be due to a copper
deficiency because copper is required to
to manufacture the elastic fibers of
arteries and skin and other tissues and
the mechanism of an aneurysm is
identical to the mechanism of a balloon
on a weaken wall of a tire you know when
you hit a Chuck hole with your tire and
you break the cords the internal
pressure blows a balloon you overload
that tire with weight or heat it up on a
highway it blows out same way with an
aneurysm when you have a copper
deficiency you get a break down of the
elastic fibers uh in that artery the
internal pressure even normal blood
pressure will blow a balloon in that
artery and a balloon in an artery is
called an aneurysm and of course if it's
in a strategic place like the brain the
crowded artery the coronary arteries the
large arteries the aart pulmonary artery
renal arteries they blow out you die
suddenly uh just like you've been shot
well they got excited about this they
double the amount of copper in these um
pellets the next year they tried to
raise 500,000 turkeys and they did not
lose a single one from a ruptured
aneurysm they went from a 50% loss to a
0% loss just by adding a little bit of
copper to those pellets so they said
well maybe the same thing is true for
humans and in 19 uh 58 they started
looking at copper deficiency in various
species of animals and humans and here's
what they found out the very first
symptom of copper deficiency is white
gray and silver hair copper is required
as a co-factor to manufacture hair
pigment doesn't matter if it's blonde
red brown or black hair and I see a lot
of copper deficiency in this room I can
almost tell you which people men and
women who have colored their hair get
pretty good at that being a physician
and you don't want to be like a medical
doctor and just treat the symptoms if
you're just coloring your hair you're
treating the symptoms you need to do the
basic thing of take some colloidal
copper and if you don't uh what's going
to happen is uh you get a breakdown of
the elastic fibers in your skin and you
start getting crows feet around the
corners of your eyes and your mouth
parts of your Anatomy begin to Sag and
you know you're in trouble when your
doctor tells you look I've got a golf
buddy down the hall who's a plastic
surgeon for $110,000 it make you look 20
years younger but you don't need a face
lift a booby lift a tummy tuck or a
dairy a lift all you need is some copper
and everything will come back up just
like you have a hydraulic jack under it
it'll just come right back up those
elastic fibers tighten right up people
say Francine did you get a facelift you
look great you look like you're 20 years
years younger now if you don't take some
action at that point the next thing that
happens is you got to break down the
elastic fibers and the large veins of
your legs and you get varicose veins you
don't take action at that point you get
to break down the elastic fibers and
large veins of your exhaust pipe and you
get hemorrhoids so if you have
hemorrhoids varicose veins things that
sag wrinkles white gray or silver here
the odds already have aneurysms
developing in you somewhere and you
don't want to of course die suddenly of
a ruptured aneurysm when your body's
been warning you for 10 20 30 years just
remember people don't die suddenly of an
aneurysm may be you drop and die think
about old Albert Einstein he died of a
ruptured a Artic aneurysm at 68 years of
age what color was his hair he was
famous for wild white hair wasn't he now
you'd like to think that people who win
the Nobel Prize in medicine would at
least live to be 75.5 but they live to
be 58 just like other doctors and of
course that's because they are trained
and they believe and they practice you
can get everything you need from your
four food groups doesn't matter if they
win the Nobel Prize or not this guy here
Dr George Kohler was the youngest person
ever to win the Nobel Prize in medicine
in history 37 years old wins a Nobel
Prize in medicine and he won the Nobel
Prize in medicine for studying
monoclonal antibodies which are
antibodies trained to attack cancer
cells if they ever get this really
working it'll be great because they
won't have to use chemotherapy anymore
which kills more people than it saves 11
years after winning the Nobel Prize in
Medicine Dr George ker now 48 drops dead
of a cardiomyopathy heart attack because
he believed you can get everything you
need from your four food groups didn't
take any selenium died of a
cardiomyopathy heart attack now I have
to tell you why athletes are early
warning system couch potatoes by
definition are people who go to
extraordinary efforts not to sweat right
they make every human effort not to
sweat they're changing the TV channels
honey bring in the popcorn I'm changing
the channels Sun bring me the TV Guide
I'm changing the channels by contrast
athletes have the attitude no pain no
gain and they're out there sweating and
working away power training strength
training running and they sweat athletes
no matter age they sweat more than five
years and couch potatoes do in 70 years
and when you sweat you don't just sweat
out potassium and Gatorade you sweat out
all 60 essential minerals if you sweat
out all of your selenium and don't
replace it by supplementation you're at
high risk of getting a cardiopathy heart
attack you sweat out all of your copper
and don't replace it by supplementation
you're at high risk of developing an
aneurysm and dying suddenly of a
ruptured aneurysm you sweat out all of
your chromium and vadium and don't
replace by supplementation and high risk
of getting diabetes and if you sweat out
all of your calcium and magnesium and
Boron and zinc and sulfur and other
minerals are required for cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue bone
you're going to get a joint and Bone
injury what is the biggest single cause
of an athlete's career being ended early
joint and Bone problems right and that's
because they sweat out all the basic
minerals that they need to maintain
those parts of their body and they don't
supplement with them because doctors
tell them that they can get everything
they need by eating their four food
groups well what are the early warning
systems for mineral deficiencies we
already told you about white gray or
silver here for a copper deficiency
liver spots are age spots in the back of
your hand side of your face or neck
these things are caused by a selenium
deficiency and you know again about
selenium deficiency then of course you
have toe cramps leg cramps so you can
have hypertension these things are all
caused by a deficiency of calcium and if
you're an athlete at age 25 or 15 and
you get a leg cramp there a Calcium
deficiency your body's telling you if
you don't stop drinking those Pepsis and
start supplementing with some calcium by
the time you're 40 50 60 years old
you're going to have arthritis and
osteoporosis but most people say wow I
got to get is high price trainer I need
somebody who can give me massage therapy
because I have a cramp and they don't go
and take their supplements 85% of the
total mineral in your body is a calcium
there's 147 different diseases you can
get from a Calcium deficiency we're just
going to quickly go over the top 10 when
it comes to number of people affected
and the amount of money involved let's
look at osteoprosis the number 10 killer
of adults in the United States remember
75% of the those over AG 65 who fracture
a hip or major leg bone don't live 90
days also it's the most horrible disease
when it comes the human misery and
dollars expended osteoporosis think of
the special Vans and the lift gates and
the ramps and the elevators the special
plumbing and homes and and public
buildings special parking places
Wheelchairs and Walkers and Canes think
of the beds and the chairs that are
little electric motors to lift you up
when you can't stand up by yourself
physical therapists joint replacement
surgeries Pharmaceuticals doctor visits
we're talking billions and billions of
dollars for nothing more than a Calcium
deficiency disease now as horrible as a
disease as osteoporosis is in human
beings we don't have oste prois in
animals because we don't have Blue Cross
Blue Shield major medical
hospitalization Medicare and Medicaid to
pay for nonsensical surgical treatments
for mineral deficiency we've learned
that by putting animals who are weaned
off their mother's milk on calcium as
soon as they're weaned they won't get
arthritis noo proces it's amazing how
that works receding gums dentist and
dental hyal tit to floss and brush after
every meal if you believe that works I
have some ocean front property in
Montana to sell you if you have receding
gums periodontitis gingivitis
pyara loose teeth Bridges and plates you
actually have osteoporosis of the facial
bones and the jaw bones we don't get
receding gums in animals even though
they don't floss or brush that's because
we've taken care of the osteoporosis
problem in animals arthritis 85% of all
arthritis is called wear and tear
arthritis osteoarthritis degenerative
arthritis ankos and spinalis these
things are nothing more than
osteoporosis of the joint ends of the
bones hypertension high blood pressure
as you've learned has nothing to do with
salt or salt restriction 85% of
hypertension not related to kidney
disease which is most of them not
related to kidney disease is in fact a
Calcium deficiency insomnia is not a
deficiency of sleeping pills helon or
barbituates it's a deficiency of calcium
kidney stones bone spurs heel spurs and
calcium deposits again the medical
profession has a malignant dumb belief
that these things are due to too much
calcium in your diet how to give up
calcium when in fact you only get kidney
stones bone spurs heel spurs and calcium
deposits when you have raging
osteoporosis you actually need need more
calcium more magnesium not less cramps
and Twitches raise your hand how many
you ever had a toe cramp foot cramp leg
cramp in your life sure that's the first
symptom of a Calcium deficiency that
most people recognize so if you've ever
had that sometime in your life you've
had a Calcium deficiency then you have
PMS the University of California San
Diego came out and said that 85% of the
emotional and physical stuff of PMs can
be relieved eliminated and cured they
use the Cure word by taking three times
the RDA of calcium low back pain has
nothing to do with problems I know
you've heard of people maybe even
yourself have had a disc surgery for
back pain and after the surgery you
still had the pain maybe even worse
because back pain is not caused by disc
problems if you have a disc problem you
can have numbness and tingling maybe
even paralysis if it's very severe but
disc problems do not cause pain we
learned in 1957 in animals that we could
prevent and cure adult onset diabetes
with two trace minerals chromium and
vadium 1985 the medical school at the
University of Vancouver British Columbia
up in Canada came out and said the trace
mineral vadium alone could replace
insulin and addal onset diabetics
Science Diet dog food has 40 minerals in
it always has chromium vadium lithium
and selenium rolon Pina laboratory rat
pellets has 28 minerals always contains
chromium vadium lithium and selenium
I'll give anybody in this room a crisp
new $100 bill if you can find me a human
infant formula off the shelf of a
grocery store that has more than 12
minerals in it none of them contain
chromium vadium or lithium only one proo
well two actually proy and INF Mill I
believe has 12 because they put in the
um selenium the rest of them don't they
have 11 10 n or eight minerals our dogs
get 40 minerals our rats get 28 and our
kids get 12 or less you don't have to be
a research scientist to realize why our
kids are now getting all these horrible
diseases that used to occur in people in
their 60s 70s and 80s all these diseases
that that um doctors are wondering how
is this genetic these kids shouldn't
have this till they're 60 well that's
because they couldn't get it out of
their little can of stuff if it's not in
the can they don't get it again we need
nutrients 16 minerals 16 vitamins 12
essential amino acids three essential
fatty acids and fortunately over the
thousands of years that human beings
have been around we haven't had to think
much about this because our food plants
our grains vegetables fruits and nuts
take carbon dioxide out of the air and
manufacture long carbon chains many of
which are vitamins amino acids and fatty
acids and this is where this medical
Kaka came from that you can get
everything you need from your four food
groups because they say well plants
grains fruits vegetables and nuts can
manufacture vitamins Amino acids and
fatty acids but we've tried this
experiment for 200 years Americans have
eaten better than anybody else in the
world we've had the best quality food in
the world over anybody else and yet we
only live to be 75.5 we don't set any
health or longevity records so if you
want to live to be over 100 can't get it
from eating your four food groups you
can live to be 75.5 you may live 10
years older 10 years younger but on the
average 75.5 so if you want to live to
be over 100 you do have to supplement
with vitamins amino acids and fatty
acids there's three types of minerals
the you have to concern yourself with
first of all there's metallic minerals
these are things like oyster shell
eggshell
Limestone Coral Calcium seabed minerals
Clays of various types Tums is a popular
one with doctors lactates gluconate
citrates oxides sulfates carbonates
these are nothing but ground of rocks
we're not designed to eat ground of
rocks nobody can show you we're humans
or animals are designed to eat ground up
rocks we're designed to get our minerals
by eating plants grains vegetables
fruits and nuts
and as a result plant derived minerals
are absorbable more absorbable than
chelated more absorbable than the
elemental or metallic minerals plant
derived minerals are liquid they're very
small particle size they're 7,000 times
smaller than a red blood cell this is
the way they're stored in your cells and
are moved around in plant vascular
systems and human vascular systems in
the um liquid plant derived form they're
negatively charged I don't know all of
the physics and chemistry is one of the
basic features of a colloidal mineral
it's negatively charged these three
factors together give you absorbability
now the way it's supposed to be is our
food plants our grains vegetables fruits
and nuts take the elemental or metallic
minerals out of the soil convert them to
minerals for their own use for their own
metabolism and biochemistry and then
animals and people eat these plants that
are enriched with minerals that's how
we're designed to get our minerals
unfortunately we have several problems
here for 100 years we've used a simple
fertilizer known as NPK we put in three
nutrients into the soil when we need 60
minerals we put those free nutrients in
the soil for maximum yields per ton and
bushel per acre uh then of course we
have to understand that plants cannot
manufacture minerals if they're not in
the soil they're not in the plants
plants only have minerals in them if
they're in the soil plants cannot
manufacture minerals over 90 years at
least we've been deficient in our soils
in America and as a result our food is
deficient and as a result the crops the
grains fruits vegetables and nuts that
are grown there are minerally deficient
and as a result the animals and people
who eat these minerally deficient crops
get mineral deficiency diseases and the
only way to prevent cure them is with
mineral
[Applause]
supplements yes I'm a construction
worker and um I hurt my back and he said
that my cartilage damage is permanent is
there anything that can be done well
first of all how old are you I'm 28
years old and what do you normally take
for fluid replacement where we working
out in construction what do you drink
during the day uh water Gatorade you
don't drink any soft drinks uh yes I do
okay cuz normally construction workers
drink a couple of liters of Pepsi a day
right yeah I can probably put down a
liter per
e and did you take any vitamins or
minerals that way we were working in
construction um just recently started
when you were in construction prior to
the back problems yeah a lot of
construction workers will tell me Well
doc if it ain't in the Pepsi I don't get
it right and so uh you're a perfect
candidate for the piger thritis formula
plus the EFA you need all 90 essential
nutrients and give up the bad things
give up up the soft drinks and the iced
tea and the lemonades and and give up
the fried foods and the margarin and uh
I can just tell you with your age uh you
can honestly expect to see some uh
really recognizable results in a very
very short time 60 to 90 days and it
doesn't matter what the doctor said if
you do the right things get rid of the
bad stuff take all 90 essential
nutrients uh making sure you get that
collagen and the glucosamine sulfate and
the condr and sulfate you will repair
your vertebrae you will repair the
cartilage and you will repair the disc
Dr Wall it just seems like every week I
pick up a newspaper and I see about our
young athletes having problems with
their bodies falling apart what can we
give our athletes and our children so
that they can be healthy and have long
lives that we want as well that's a
great question because most people
believe that exercise is good for you
and that was always a great question you
know is exercise good for you is it
necessary for Health and Longevity and
when you inspect this question uh you
have to look at professional athletes
who uh spend most of their teenage years
and going through University and the
semi-pros and the pros uh training and
practicing and doing their events and if
exercise was the factor in living a long
healthful life athletes should live
longer than couch potatoes but when you
look at this critically couch potatoes
in America live to be 75.5 and the
average athlete depending on the sport
and their level of competence live to be
62 to 68 far short of what a couch
potato lives to be and of course
athletes suffer from a great many joint
diseases and Bone injuries and tendons
and ligaments back necks shoulders
ankles knees and hips and have to suffer
through an enormous amount of surgeries
to deal with this and athletes develop
some 800 different diseases and what is
it why is it that athletes don't fare as
well as the couch potato well it's
simply because athletes sweat more in 5
years than couch potatoes do in 75 years
and when you sweat you're not just
sweating out Gatorade you're sweating
out all 60 essential minerals and
they're called essential minerals
because if they're missing for any
length of time you get some horrible
degenerative disease many of which are
are life-threatening so you don't have
to be a rocket scientist to figure out
who's more likely to be debilitated or
even die of these these life-threatening
diseases an athlete who sweats out
quarts of sweat during an event or
training or practice or a couch potato
who's laying on a couch in an air
conditioned Den switching the channels
yelling honey bring in the popcorn I'm
changing the channels and this is very
ser ious because the Center for Disease
Control says that as many as 100,000
young athletes under the age of 30
100,000 each year die suddenly during an
event or training or exercise or
immediately after an event from
cardiopathy heart disease and ruptured
aneurysm and we know that cardiopathy
heart disease is due to a selenium
deficiency and ruptured aneurysms is due
to a copper deficiency so it can begin
to put two and two together why does a
10-year-old die of a ruptured aneurysm
well he sweat out all of his copper and
you can't get copper from curly french
fries and Pepsis it just doesn't work Dr
wallak what about arthritis well
arthritis is my favorite disease because
it's easy to fix uh it's one of the
great myths that the medical profession
perpetuates is that you can't build bone
mass after the age of 50 60 70 years of
age you can only slow down the loss and
the reason why they say that is because
they try to rebuild bone mass using
plain calcium whether it's Tums or
calcium citrate or carbonate or glucan
Ator or lactate and your body will not
retain much or any of the calcium you
supplement within your bones without
first building new bone matrix you have
to have new bone matrix this is this
this rubbery collagen material that
looks like tend in or skin and it makes
up 25 to 40% of our bone weight 40% when
you're a child and 25% when you're an
adult and so it's absolutely essential
if you want to deal with the wear and
tear arthritis osteoarthritis
degenerative arthritis ankos and
spondilitis effectively you have to take
all 90 essential nutrients and the best
way to do that is with Dr Wall's Pig
arthritis formula remember I'm a
veterinarian as well as a physician and
we learned a long time ago maybe 100
years ago in veterinary medicine that we
could actually prevent and reverse maybe
even use the Cure word in animals
arthritis simply by giving the animal
the raw material to develop properly and
to maintain and repair the joints and so
using this information that we developed
in animals if you use the same concept
for human beings I have literally seen
tens of thousands of people over the
years who had bone to bone arthritis
they had osteoarthritis they have
degenerative arthritis anking spinalis
which are basically a joint form of
osteoporosis it's osteoporosis The Joint
ends of the bones and they've tried all
kinds of medication and of course if you
take medication if you take a painkiller
if you take an anti-inflammatory for
arthritis essentially all you're doing
is cutting the wire to the red warning
light pain in a joint says don't use me
until you fix me and by taking a pain
killer by taking a anti-inflammatory
which will reduce pain you're allowing
that joint to be used even though it
would have been painful without the drug
and so you're wearing that joint out
faster and faster and faster and to me
it's criminally negligent for someone to
be prescribed a painkiller or an
anti-inflammatory for joint disease
without repairing The Joint at the same
time and this is where the pig thus
formula really shines and works just
like a charm in human beings so does the
same apply for bone spurs absolutely
bone spurs are a manifestation of
osteoporosis a person will get bone
spurs and calcium deposits when you have
osteoporosis just the opposite of what a
doctor will tell you and you need more
calcium more magnesium you need the bone
matrix you need the collagen the
glucosamine sulfate the condr and
sulfate and those bone spurs and the
calcium deposits will actually re
architecture back down to a normal bone
takes a little while takes 4 to 6 months
to pull that off but you can do it on a
regular basis absolutely cancer seems to
be striking everywhere in our population
these days what do we have that we can
help people that are facing the
challenge of cancer that's a great
question uh back at the turn of the
century 1895 1900 one out of 10
Americans developed cancer right now
it's 3 out of five and by the year 2050
it's projected two out of three people
are going to develop cancer America the
onset of cancer appears to be directly
related to the amount of of
carcinogens these are toxic waste either
from agriculture or from the Industrial
Waste that we find in our air and our
food and our water and in the dust
around us and the lack of the ability to
defend against these these carcinogens
and the most common defense mechanism
that we have the one that we have access
to in a very economical way are the
antioxidants like selenium
like the grape seed extract like the
green tea you're looking at Vitamin E
vitamin C beta carotene and avoiding
fried foods and margins and and things
that we have control of eating as much
our gly grown food as possible and
according to the medical school at the
University of Arizona and this came out
in jamama the Journal of the American
Medical Association December 25th 1996 I
mean we're talking about a great
Christmas gift to the American people
they did a wonderful study 10 years it
was a doubleblind study 1300 people they
gave the study group 250 micrograms
which is one qu of 1 milligram and we're
talking an itsy bitsy amount of selenium
they just use selenium alone didn't
change anything else and by giving these
people 250 micrograms one qu of a
milligram of the trace mineral selenium
they were able to reduce the risk of
esophageal cancer by 71% prostate cancer
by 69% greater than 2/3 colon and rectal
canc cancer by 64% almost 2/3 lung
cancer was reduced by 48% whether you
smoked or not and in a parallel study
from the University of California San
Diego 250 micrograms one qu of 1
milligram of selenium the trace Minal
selenium reduce the risk of breast
cancer by 50 to 80% and the same study
showed that if you already have cancer
if you take 250 micrograms of selenium
every day uh you will in fact double the
Natural History life expectancy of a
particular type of cancer for instance
lung cancer the Natural History is about
a year brain cancer is less than a year
uterine ovarian colon breast cancer is 2
to 5 years prostate cancer is 5 to 8
years well just by taking 250 micrograms
of the trace Minal selum every day one
qu of 1 milligram according to the
University of of Arizona's Medical
School uh you can double that life
expectancy just by doing that one thing
and so if you take the other
antioxidants and give up margins and
fried foods and sugar and caffeine and
avoid as many of the Agricultural waste
and the toxic waste from the industry
that you can you will be able to avoid
an enormous amount of cancer and if you
already have cancer doing other things
such as taking the um antioxidants and
getting on macrobiotic diets and and so
forth you can add many healthful years
to your life you can certainly have a
better quality of life and many people
uh will extend their lives and in a
great way 10 20 30 40 years and
obviously there's no way you can look in
somebody's eyes and say you're the one
that's going to live 50 years
and so people just have to do all the
right things and they're going to get
the best that can be gotten from
nutrition and the the supplements Dr
Wall like I've been a diabetic for about
30 years what can what kind of minerals
should I take to help me okay well first
of all are you an adult onset type 2
diabetic or a juvenile onset type 1
diabetic juvenile onset type 1 you are
in insulin dependent because the
definition of a juvenile onset type 1
diabetic is that you do not make any
insulin and so you will never be able to
to wean off of insulin you will always
have to take some insulin but uh there
are two trace minerals chromium and
vadium that will make the insulin that
you supplement yourself with very
efficient and most people who are
juvenile onset type 1 diabetics are able
to reduce the amount of insulin they
require to stabilize their blood sugar
uh by supplementing with the chromium
and vadium normally a person learns how
to adjust their insulin by taking their
blood sugar once or twice or three times
a day and so you're how to adjust your
insulin intake and just by following
what you've been taught as you
supplement with this plant derived
colloidal and the chelated chromium and
vadium you will be able to get down to a
new dosage of your insulin and the value
of taking the whole pig arthritis
formula is that there's nothing worse
than paying attention to your blood
sugar levels your insulin intake and
then dying of a ruptured aneurysm
because you didn't supplement with
copper or developing cancer because you
didn't supplement with selenium so it's
very important even though you're a
diabetic and that is your primary
immediate concern still over the Long
Haul of being a health conscious person
just out of necessity uh you're going to
have to supplement with all 90 essential
nutrients and uh the odds are even
though you're a juvenile onset type 1
diabetic you have every honest
expectation of living to be 100 symptom
free if you do everything right yes my
question is on Alzheimer's why is it
more prevalent today that than it was 15
20 years ago actually Alzheimer's
disease was a disease that did not exist
40 years ago uh Alzheimer's disease even
by another name could not be found in
any medical dictionary or textbook or
taught in any medical curriculum it only
became an entity in the medical
literature 1979 and today it's
apparently the number four killer of
adults in United States over the age of
65 behind cardiovascular disease cancer
diabetes and then comes Alzheimer's
disease and it it appears uh to me with
no no doubt that it's due to what I call
a physician caused disease because
doctors have have encouraged people in
fact demanded that people give up
saturated fat and cholesterol and move
towards a cholesterol restricted or even
a cholesterol-free diet to get their
blood cholesterol down below 200 and
they have created no less than 25 of
these cholesterol deficiency diseases
and to me Alzheimer's disease is one of
the big ones 75% of our brain weight is
pure cholesterol it's called myin it's
this fatty stuff that insulates each
nerve fiber the brain and spinal cord
and we can only make about 10% of our
daily need of cholesterol the other 90%
must come from the diet and if a person
is very very good at giving up chicken
skin and red meat and dairy and eggs
like a doctor would have them do after
about six or eight or 10 years they're
not going to be able to keep up with the
maintenance and repair needs of the
cholesterol for the myin and the brain
and spinal cord and so you can just
expect that the person is going to
develop one or more of these 25
physician caused diseases including
acquired seizure disorders and
Alzheimer's disease now the best way to
avoid Alzheimer's disease is to eat a
couple of eggs every morning for
breakfast not cooked in margin or fried
uh you want to consume as much as 72
ounces of red meat every month and I
know that sounds like a lot but it's
just a quarter pounder a day and uh you
want to supplement with all 90 essential
nutrients and when you get to the the
vitamin E level you want to have at
least 2,000 international units of
vitamin E and you want 500 macrs of
selenium and if you do that even if you
already have Alzheimer's disease you can
expect to have a significant amount of
Return of memory great study done by the
University of California San Diego and
the sock Institute that says by taking
2,000 international units of vitamin E
alone even if you have advanced
Alzheimer's disease you can get a
significant amount of of memory return
I've remodeled homes for families you
notice these little children bouncing
off of walls and what they get for
breakfast and a snack after breakfast
and then lunch again
normally has sugar in it is there any uh
correlation here with ADD absolutely
back the turn of the century 1895 to
1900 Americans were eating a half a
pound of sugar per person per year today
it's 150 lbs of sugar per person per
year and somebody out there is eating
300 lb because I don't eat any and I can
tell you that there's a direct
correlation between the increase in ADD
ADHD depression manic depression bipolar
disease and the increased consumption of
sugar and if you look at it there's 5
million American children school age
children who are on riddlin and Prozac
and mamine and other anti-depressants in
school 5 million drugged American kids
in in preschool and Elementary School
simply because these kids are sensitive
to Sugar like many people are sensitive
to alcohol uh there's good alcoholics
who just kind of go to sleep when they
have a couple of drinks uh there's the
people who get boisterous and sing loud
Irish songs when they take take a couple
of drinks and there are some people who
get violent and and very angry and
become dangerous to themselves and other
people uh child abuse spouse abuse they
abuse their neighbors road rage is
another way of looking at this uh
life-threatening situations uh people
actually will gain criminal Behavior
sometimes because alcohol acts like a
drug in them same way with sugar some
people when they take in Sugar they have
low blood sugar and they just get drowsy
and fall asleep some people when they
take in Sugar they get hyperactive and
boisterous and uh actually um ADD
ADHD and then there's some people when
they take in Sugar again will have road
rage uh they're very very um aggressive
and reactive and could be dangerous to
themselves and their families and other
people in the community and to me it's
criminal for Coca-Cola machines and and
candy machines in school and then wonder
why kids beat up on each other shoot
Each Other Well in addition to getting
all the sugar out of their life from
sugar Frosted Flakes and Pepsis and
rees's peanut buttercups and candy and
and Pop-Tarts and syrup on their AOS uh
they have to supplement with all 90
essential nutrients even little kids
from the moment they're born to develop
properly this includes their emotions
and repair and maintain themselves and
especially lithium chromium and vadium
and there's an enormous amount of
research in human beings which show that
lithium deficiency results in
hyperactivity ADD ADHD depression manic
depression and criminal behavior and so
they have to do both and you can avoid
all this uh it's amazing just within
days they will be perfectly normal
little kids my next question is my
husband and I are thinking about
starting a family and we want to know
the nutritional way to go okay that's a
great question people always ask me when
when do children need to start taking
vitamins and minerals and the answer is
when they're still an egg is when you
want to start them and so uh we've
learned in the animal industry and
remember I'm a veterinarian as well as a
physician we've learned in the animal
industry that we could prevent as much
as 98% of all birth effects even ones
that are thought to be genetic in humans
simply by giving the females especially
the females all known essential
nutrients for that species 6 months
prior to conception build up that female
animals body and stores of these
essential nutrients so that the embryo
implants in the uterine wall and
develops in an environment that has
optimal amounts guaranteed optimal
amounts of all the nutrients and you
will almost eliminate the possibility of
A congenital birth effect related to a
mineral or vitamin or amino acid or
essential fatty acid deficiency to give
you some idea of how successful this is
according to the University of
California San Francisco right now in
America one out of every 33 human babies
in America are born with some physical
or emotional or mental birth Effect one
out of 33 in animals it's only one out
of 500,000 if they're fed these
commercial diets that have all the known
nutrients in them and so it's just very
very easy to understand well if we
supplement young women and men who are
in the childbearing Years with these
nutrients that will be able to eliminate
totally eliminate cleft pallets cleft
lips spinabifida eye defects heart
defects hernas of various types club
feet no feet web fingers and toes no
fingers and toes uh muscular distrophy
Down syndrome cerebral paly cystic
fibrosis these are all preventable with
proper preconception nutrition so the
earlier that a couple who wants to uh
have normal healthy children and have a
wonderful uncomplicated pregnancy the
earlier you can get on all 90 essential
nutrients prior to conception the better
off everybody is hello Dr wallik the
women in my family are plagued with hay
fever and asthma and allergies and I
don't want to join those ranks is there
a better way absolutely uh let's start
with asthma it's the easiest one to deal
with asthma is actually a deficiency of
three nutrients magnesium manganese and
the essential fatty acids and by taking
the pig arthritis formula twice a day
you're going to get the optimal amounts
of the plant- derived colloid and the
chelated magnesium and manganese and
then by taking the minimum daily
requirement the N gram of the essential
fatty acids and those three nutrients
together the Magnesium manganese and the
essential fatty acids will allow you to
produce what's called prostaglandins
prostaglandins are little short-lived
hormones that last in your bloodstream
30 seconds 60 seconds and your body is
continuously making them kind of Rapid
Fire and when you don't have those three
nutrients you cannot make the proper
prostaglandins to keep your Bron ey and
your trachea open and that's when you
develop asthma and it's very common when
people take all 90 essential nutrients
including the magnesium and manganese
and the essential fatty acids within
weeks or months the tightness this
constant tightness in their chest is
significantly reduced or maybe even
totally relieved the frequency and the
severity of their asthma attacks is
reduced I would certainly still keep an
inhaler available until she you know in
case she has some unexpected emergency
kind of like wearing your seat belt even
though you're on a smooth flight you
you're not going to uh anticipate sudden
turbulence you need to be prepared for
emergencies but um you have very honest
expectation of doing very well then as
far as inhalent allergies from dust and
pollin and uh seasonal ones from dust
and pollin and maybe constant ones from
danders and cats and dogs and chickens
and feathers and your pillows and that
kind of thing maybe even chemicals that
come out of rugs and formica and new
cars like f Malahide and other chemicals
um you want to get your immune system
working optimally so it can protect you
from these things because most people
are able to tolerate them and what
happens is when your immune system
doesn't have enough nutrition to
function optimally uh you become a
victim of these things assaulting you
all the time and so what you want to do
is number one take all 90 essential
nutrients so your immune system which
includes your liver and your spleen your
tonsils and your appendix your thymus uh
your um white blood cells which include
the nutrifil and the lymphocytes and the
killer tea cells and so forth also you
have eosinophils and basophils you have
neutrophils all of these white blood
cells you have albumins and globulins
which are the the immune proteins you
have antibodies themselves you have your
digestive system your skin your tears
the mucus in your body all of that
requires 90 nutrients to produce this
immune system which is not just your
killer tea cells uh it it includes all
of these tissues and and cells and
organs of your body uh also if you have
these types of problems you want to get
some of these HEPA filters uh at your
workplace in your home when you sleep
you get the ones that you plug in your
car you want to eat as much organically
grown food as possible you want to drink
filtered Waters you want to get as much
chemicals out of your diet as possible
and reduce this pressure on your immune
system system if you have food allergies
you want to have a 5day rotation diet
you want to take the enzyme which has
the pepsin and the betan hydrochloride
which will help a person digest the
proteins down into single amino acid and
it's the proteins and the allergens such
as danders and foods and pollin and dust
that cause the the allergies and even
can initiate an attack of asthma thank
you you're very welcome is it possible
that you can take too much that's a
great question because people are
concerned about overdosing with vitamins
and minerals the general answer is that
if you look at the medical profession
according to the Center for Disease
Control Harvard Medical School the US
News and World Report Ralph nater Sydney
wolf Rand Corporation and many many
other well-respected
institutions they say that doctors kill
150,000 to 300,000 Americans each year
in hospitals alone as a result of
medical negligence doctors injure 1.3
million Americans each year in hospitals
alone as a result of medical negligence
and doctors infect 2 million Americans
alone in hospitals as a result of
medical negligence for a total of three
and a half million casualties inflicted
on the American public each year in
hospitals just as as a result of medical
negligence on the other side of this
picture there's not a single person
who's overdosed in vitamins and minerals
and trace minerals to the point where
they have to be hospitalized or anything
bad happened and so when you compare the
safety of vitamins and minerals and
trace minerals compared with standard
medical procedure procedures it's
enormously safe and that's why I'm so
excited about nutrition and the pig
arthritis formula and the plant derived
choral minerals and that's the direction
I'd go Dr wallik my 16-year-old daughter
has been diagnosed with fibromyalgia
what can you do for her well it's
actually an easy one we eliminated
fibromyalgia in animals in
1957 and in sheep it was called stiff
lamb disease and also in sheep and
calves and fos with baby horses and
chickens and turkeys and any any other
animal that was raised for meat
uh the disease is uh caused by a
deficiency of three nutrients the trace
mineral selenium vitamin E and the
sulfur bearing amino acid methionine and
there's two things you have to do to
deal with fibromy number one eliminate
the free radicals and the trans fatty
acids that actually initiate damage to
the muscle and cause a scarring of the
muscle tissue which is very painful even
normal muscle movement and you can
understand why they call it stiff lamb
disease if you have
fibromyalgia first of all you eliminate
fried foods such as fried potatoes which
are you know teenagers live on fried
potatoes right so you have to eliminate
fried potatoes Fried Chicken fish shrimp
fried eggs uh tempura stir fry anything
fried all margarine salad dressings with
oils in them have to be eliminated and
then again the pig arthritis form is
perfect because it has optimal amounts
of the trace mineral selenium in both
the plant derived colloidal and the
chelated form it has optimal amounts of
vitamin E and the sulfur bearing amino
acid methine and it just works like a
charm very quickly within weeks or
months so they feel and they can
recognize some benefit and many people
will get significant benefit very
quickly Dr wck are baby formulas enough
for our babies when they're born
unfortunately not our our formulas that
we give to dogs whether it's kind of
like um sciat dog food are the puppy or
kitten milk replacers for puppies and
kittens you're going to raise by hand
have 40 minerals in them including the
uh minerals um lithium chromium vadium
and selenium Ral chpro laboratory rat
pellets contain 28 minerals including
lithium chromium vadium and selenium
there's not a single human mil replacer
on the market on a off the shelf of a
grocery store that has more than 12
minerals none of them contain lithium
chromium vadium and only two pro soybean
infam have selenium in them and uh it's
tragic that we give our dogs 40 minerals
and our rats 28 and our kids 12 or less
you can begin to see why we spent $1.2
trillion for healthc care last year you
begin to see why we only live to be
75.5 half of our genetic potential for
longevity of 120 to 140 why we only rank
17th in longevity in 19th in
healthfulness simply because we don't
get the basic raw materials to develop
properly and maintain repair cells from
the very beginning I'll give you a
tragic example sudden infant death
syndrome is something everybody is
familiar with we eliminated sudden
infant death syndrome in animals back in
the 1950s because Farmers can't afford
to lose two or three or 5 or 10% of the
animals are raising to sudden infant
death syndrome and we learned that it
was due to a deficiency of the trace
Minal slum causing sudden death and the
most robust the healthiest of the baby
animals in in the group or the herd or
the flock and we eliminate it simply by
giving the pregnant mothers selenium and
as soon as the baby is born or hatch
they get selenium and if you look at the
human infant milk replacers on the
market only two of all of them put
selenium in the formula and so if I was
going to raise a child today on these
infant milk replacers these infant milk
formulas in a can or a bottle or a box I
would pick the
two pro soybean infam Mill that have
selenium in them and to stack things in
favor of the child I would still give
them from the moment they're Barn a
teaspoon for 20 pounds of body weight of
the pig arthritis froma twice a day
obviously you may not want to use the
orange juice in a new barn baby because
it can develop allergies to it but I
would still give them the plant derived
Cal and the chelated minerals and V vins
and amino acids and the tragic example
of this is 65% this is a known fact 65%
of all the babies dying of sudden infant
DND Drome in America are being fed
canned milk replacers 2/3 of the ones
who die of sudden infant death syndrome
are being fed these canned infant
formulas and I guarantee you they're
being fed the ones that don't have
selenium in them and so uh absolutely
it's important to supplement these
babies from birth because you can't get
everything you need from your for Food
Group C not out of these canned formulas
great thank
you